WE CERTAINLY HOPE YOU ALL HAD A
HAPPY THANKSGIVING WITH A LOT OF
DELICIOUS FEASTING WITH FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE REST OF THE
SHOW, LET'S GO AROUND THE TABLE.
SEE HOW EVERYONE'S THANKSGIVING
WAS.
WE HAVE TO START WITH YOU, GREG.
>> IT WAS GREAT.
THE PRODUCERS ASKED US IF WE'D
SUPPLY PICTURES.
SO I DID.
THIS IS THE TURKEY.
THAT'S A BOWL OF STUFFING.
THE STUFFING WAS GREAT.
I WENT OFF MY ATKINS DIET AND
HAD SOME STUFFING.
THERE WAS GREEN BEANS.
I WAS AT A RESTAURANT.
>> THEY SERVE CORN ON THE COB ON
THANKSGIVING?
>> I THINK I HAVE A PICTURE OF
ME AND THE PEOPLE I WAS WITH.
THERE IS SEAN, LAURA, TUCKER,
AND ME.
PEOPLE ENJOYING A NICE MEAL.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO OUTSIDE OF
WORK.
>> THAT LOOKS VERY FUN.
THAT LOOKS VERY FUN.
>> LAWRENCE, YOU ARE IN DALLAS?
>> I COOK.
MY MOM HAD LUPUS GROWING UP SO
SHE TAUGHT ME HOW TO COOK VERY
EARLY.
A LOT OF MY FAMILY GOT TOGETHER
AND TALK POLITICS, ACTUALLY.
IT DIDN'T PLAY THAT WAY BECAUSE
MY MOM ALREADY SAID NONE OF
THAT, HERE'S PECAN PIE.
BUT IT WAS VERY CIVIL.
NOBODY WAS SCREAMING AT EACH
OTHER.
WE NATURALLY TALK LOUD, BUT IT
WAS WELL.
>> WE SHOWED PICTURES OF
OURSELVES.
YOU SHOWED PICTURE OF THE FOOD
YOU MADE.
>> MY MOTHER IS 92.
SHE IS SHARP AS A TACK.
ME AND A FRIEND WENT OUT TO A
HOTEL AND MY MOTHER HAD WHATEVER
SHE WANTED WITH THE ACTIVE
SUPPORT AND LOVE OF HER SON.
IT WAS THE RIGHT KIND OF
THANKSGIVING.
THANKS FOR ASKING.
>> SHE EARNED THAT.
>> I FELT PROUD.
>> THIS IS YOUR FIRST TIME ON
"THE FIVE."
I HOPE MY MOTHER IS WATCHING BUT
THANK YOU, MOM, FOR EVERYTHING.
ALL THE LOVE AND SUPPORT YOU'VE
GIVEN ME.
>> DOES SHE STILL HAVE A
COCKTAIL?
>> SHE HAS A COCKTAIL WHATEVER
SHE WANTS WITH MY SUPPORT AND
LOVE.
SHE IS SHARPER THAN I AM.
>> WHAT'S HER COCKTAIL OF
CHOICE?
>> HER COCKTAIL OF CHOICE IS PER
CYCLE.
THE ONLY THING SHE SAYS TO ME,
HOW DO YOU AS A CENTRIST TURNED
OUT AS YOU DID, BECAUSE SHE'S
FAR LEFT.
>> WE COOKED.
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME WE COOKED.
>> TURKEY OR NO TURKEY?
>> FOR HIS FIRST TURKEY, IT WAS
DELICIOUS!
MY DOG WAS THERE.
SHE HAD SO MUCH FOOD.
SHE HAD TURKEY, SWEET POTATO,
APPLESAUCE.
MY ANGEL.
I MADE A GLUTEN-FREE STUFFING
THAT I WAS TERRIFIED WAS GOING
TO BE AWFUL BUT WAS ACTUALLY
DELICIOUS.
>> DO YOU DO THAT BECAUSE YOU
HAVE ISSUES WITH GLUTEN OR --
>> HERE WE GO...
TOO TRENDY FOR YOU, GREG?
>> YOU HAD STICKS, DIDN'T YOU?
>> I HAD A RIBEYE.
IT WAS SO GOOD.
NOTHING GLUTEN-FREE ABOUT IT.
>> WHAT ABOUT THEY KNOW?
WHAT DID YOU DO?
>> I TOOK A BUNCH OF PICTURES OF
MY DOG.
>> HOW IS THIS ANY DIFFERENT?
>> THIS IS THE TABLE.
WE WERE DOWN IN NEW JERSEY.
MY MOM AND HER FRIEND BARB ARE
HERE IN TOWN AND PETER AND I, WE
ALL WENT TO THE YACHT CLUB AND
WE JOINED ON WITH A LANDER
FAMILY.
THEY HAVE A BIG FAMILY.
WE HAVE A SMALL LITTLE FAMILY.
WE GOT TO BE A PART OF THEM.
THAT WAS REALLY FUN.
PICTURES OF MY DOG!
THAT'S THE ONLY THING I WANT.
>> THE INTERESTING FACT I TOLD
YOU TODAY ABOUT THE AUTHOR?
>> THE C IS SILENT IN YACHT.
>> WE LEARN SOMETHING NEW FROM
YOU EVERY DAY, GREG.
IF YOU WATCHED FACEBOOK LIVE...
>> YOU CAN WIN THESE PICTURES.
>> WE CAN WIN THESE PICTURES?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M THINKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
>> I HAVE TO GET BACK ON THE
DIET RIGHT NOW.
>> I'M JEALOUS, LAWRENCE.
51 POUNDS --
>> YOU EAT WHATEVER YOU WANT,
ENJOY YOUR FAMILY, YOU GO BACK
ON IT.
>> DID YOU BUY BUY A BUNCH O
>> DID YOU BUY BUY A BUNCH F
>> DID YOU BUY BUY A BUNCH N
>> DID YOU BUY BUY A BUNCH W
CLOTHES?
>> BLACK FRIDAY SHOPPING.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO, BUT WE
HAVE TO MOVE ON TO THE
BORDER BATTLE THAT'S HEATING UP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENING TO
SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE BORDER IF
MEXICO DOES NOT CONTROL THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN HEADING OUR WAY.
>> IF WE FIND THAT IT GETS TO A
LEVEL WHERE WE ARE GOING TO LOSE
CONTROL OR PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
START GETTING HURT, WE WILL LOSE
ENTRY INTO THE COUNTRY FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME.
I'VE ALREADY SHUT DOWN PARTS OF
THE BORDER BECAUSE IT WAS OUT OF
CONTROL, WITH THE WRITING ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
COULD THERE BE A SHUTDOWN?
THERE CERTAINLY COULD.
IT'LL BE ABOUT BORDER SECURITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT ALSO SAID HE'S
AUTHORIZING ACTIVE-DUTY TROOPS
TO AUTHORIZE FOR US IF THEY HAVE
TO.
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IF CONGRESS
DOESN'T MOVE ON SHUTTING DOWN
THE WALL.
THE FORMER ACTING I.C.E.
DIRECTOR TO SECURE THE BORDER
NOW OR ELSE HE'LL DON'T MAKE
THE SITUATION WILL GET WORSE.
>> THE REASON THERE IS A CARAVAN
ON THE BORDER, THE REASON THE
NUMBERS ARE HIGH RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE CONGRESS HAS FAILED TO
ACT.
THEY'VE FAILED TO CLOSE
LOOPHOLES BECAUSE OF HIS
CARAVANS.
EVERYBODY IS WATCHING WHAT'S
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
IF WE DO NOT SECURE THIS BORDER,
IF WE LET THESE PEOPLE COMING
AND THEY GET RELEASED, NOT TO
SHOW UP IN COURT, EVEN IF THEY
SHOW UP IN COURT, DON'T LEAVE.
IF WE DON'T HAVE A HARD RESPONSE
AND PROTECT THE SOVEREIGNTY OF
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW, THERE IS
GOING TO BE MORE CARAVANS.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> I WAS SAYING THAT I CAN SEE
THE FUTURE THAT THIS ISSUE IS
GOING TO COME TO A HEAD AND IT'S
GOING TO BE SOLVED.
CONGRESS IS GOING TO BE
-- YOU TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION
AT THE THINGS GIVING TABLE?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
THE ONLY ISSUE MY FAMILY AGREES
WITH TRUMP ON IS IMMIGRATION.
MY GRANDMOTHER MADE IT VERY
CLEAR.
"SON, I MAY NOT LIKE
DONALD TRUMP, BUT ONE THING I
WILL DO IS HELP THEM BUILD THAT
WALL."
AND A LOT OF BLACK FOLKS AGREE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE
BECAUSE FREEDOM HAS NEVER BEEN
SOMETHING THAT HIS FREE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU FIGHT
FOR.
BLOOD IN THE SOIL PURE THAT'S
WHAT A LOT OF AMERICANS SEE.
WILL CONGRESS GET IT DONE?
I DON'T THINK SO, BECAUSE BOTH
POLITICAL PARTIES BENEFIT FROM
THIS CONTROVERSY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS CAVED ON THE
ISSUE A LITTLE BIT.
HE SAID, LOOK, I WILL GIVE YOU
CITIZENS FOR DACA PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS ARE
WILLING TO CAVE BECAUSE OF THE
OPTICS OF THE WALL, EVEN THOUGH
MANY OF THEM PREVIOUSLY HAD THE
POSITION OF SUPPORTING THE WALL,
A LOT OF THEM DON'T SUPPORT IT
NOW.
>> I THINK WE DEMOCRATS WOULD
BENEFIT FROM A COMPROMISE.
DO BORDER SECURITY, DO THE WALL,
DO DACA, AND TRY TO GET A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP BECAUSE
THESE ISSUES HURT THE DEMOCRATS
AND IT'S CLEAR IT WOULD HELP THE
REPUBLICANS TOO.
TRUMP MADE THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN
ABOUT IMMIGRATION, ABOUT THE
CARAVAN.
IT DIDN'T DO SO WELL IN THE
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS.
FOR HIM TO BROADEN HIS APPEAL
FOR 2020, A DEAL WOULD HELP
THEM.
MY ADVICE IN THE LAME DUCK
SESSION?
START THE PROCESS OF GETTING IT
DONE.
TIE IT TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
IT WOULD EVEN BE BETTER.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH TO
GET IMMIGRATION DONE AT THE LAME
DUCK?
>> BUT WE'VE GOT TO TRY.
ULTIMATELY IT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGHER FOR THE REPUBLICANS
AFTER THE NEW CONGRESS IS SWORN
IN WITH NANCY PELOSI.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
I'M AN OPTIMIST.
I FEEL LIKE SOMETHING TO GET
DONE, JEDEDIAH, BUT THESE GUYS
ARE TELLING ME IT COULD BE
TOUGH.
>> THIS IS THE KEY ISSUE THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAN ON.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE RAN ON IS
IMMIGRATION.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE WALL
EXTENSIVELY.
I THINK IF THERE IS AN ISSUE FOR
HIM TO REALLY HIT HOME ON AND --
LOOK, IF YOU GOT TO SHUT THE
GOVERNMENT DOWN, I KNOW PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT AND SOME PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT FREAK OUT WHEN HE'S
TALKING ABOUT A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
TO GET TO THE LEFT, THEY MARKET
IT WELL.
THEY DO NOT TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT SO MANY ESSENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES ACTUALLY
CONTINUE WHEN YOU HAVE A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE TIDE IS
TURNING ON IT, GREG.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE EVERY
SINGLE DAY FOR YEARS.
IT FEELS LIKE, TO ME, IT'S
COMING TO A HEAD AND MIGHT GET
TO A GOOD PLACE.
>> WELL, I'M A LITTLE
PESSIMISTIC AS WELL.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT FOR
DONALD TRUMP, THIS IS A CENTRAL
CONCERN OF HIS THAT HAS A LONG
IN HIS HEAD BUT HAS A SHORT-TERM
COST.
YOU DON'T GET GOOD P.R., THE
MEDIA HATES YOU, YOU'RE PAINTED
AS A BIGOT, ALL THE SHORT TERM
KUNKEL WINCES TO BENEFIT WHICH
IS THE CHANGES IN
IMMIGRATION IS NOT BEING KEPT UP
WITH THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
WE UPDATE OUR PHONE EVERY YEAR.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WE REFUSE
TO UPDATE FOR FEAR OF BEING
YELLED AT.
IMMIGRATION HIGHLIGHTS THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
CONSTRAINED AND UNCONSTRAINED.
THEY BELIEVE HUMANS ARE
FALLIBLE, THEY WILL GAME THE
SYSTEM.
YOU NEED TO HAVE A PROCESS.
BUT THE LEFT, UNCONSTRAINED,
BELIEVE IN MORAL PROGRESS, AND
THAT LAWS ARE JUST TEMPORARY.
>> THE ANSWER IS NOT MORAL
PROGRESS.
IT'S POLITICAL BENEFIT.
IF TRUMP IS FLEXIBLE ON WHAT THE
WALL IS AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FLEXIBLE ON TERMS FOR DACA AND
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP, THE BIG
WINNER WILL BE DONALD TRUMP --
SPEAK OF THE PROGRESSIVE WING OF
THE PARTY --
>> I'M NOT A PROGRESSIVE IN CASE
YOU'VE NOTICED --
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT THE ENERGY OF
YOUR PARTY IS.
>> SADLY, YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
OPEN BORDER.
>> YOU HAVE TO PLEASE THOSE
PEOPLE --
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO PLEASE
THOSE PEOPLE.
>> SHE DOESN'T HAVE THE FULL
SUPPORT OF OUR CAUCUS NOW --
>> SHE DOES.
>> SO WITH THAT BASE OF THE
PARTY, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO SET
THEM UP?
WE ARE NOT.
>> WE DON'T NEED TO SET THEM UP.
WE NEED TO GET THE REPUBLICANS
TO DO A DEAL THAT WILL BENEFIT
TRUMP, BENEFIT THE DEMOCRATS,
BENEFIT THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU KNOW HOW THIS WORKS,
THOUGH.
>> I DO.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO SAY, LET'S
TALK ABOUT A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
AND ONCE THIS IS ALL FIGURED OUT
AND WE HAVE GOVERNMENTS OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM, THEN WE CANT
IMMIGRATION REFORM, THEN WE CANB
IMMIGRATION REFORM, THEN WE CANU
IMMIGRATION REFORM, THEN WE CANT
BORDER SECURITY.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, JEDEDIAH.
IT'S GOT TO BE BORDER SECURITY
FIRST.
>> I WANT TO MAKE ONE LAST POINT
AND WILL GO.
IF BOTH SIDES BENEFIT FROM IT
POLITICALLY FROM IT BEING AN
ISSUE, WHY CAN'T THE SAME BE
TRUE THAT BOTH SIDES WOULD BE
BENEFITING --
>> YOU'RE LEAVING OUT ONE
CENTRAL PIECE, THAT IS THE MEDIA
WHICH BENEFITS FROM PLAYING
SANTA.
IT GOES BACK TO THE SHORT-TERM
CONSEQUENCES, THEY GET TO
COLLEGE FROM A RACIST, CALL
CONSERVATIVES BIGOTS, YOU
CAN IGNORE THE LONG-TERM
BENEFITS WHICH WILL MAKE THE
COUNTRY SAFER TO HAVE AN IMMIGRA
COUNTRY SAFER TO HAVE AN IMMIGRI
COUNTRY SAFER TO HAVE AN IMMIGRN
SYSTEM THAT MATCHES THE CURRENT
CHALLENGES.
IT'S HARD TO BE THE ADULT.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW, TALKING ABOUT WALLS.
THAT'S THE ADULT FILTER.
THE MEDIA HAS THE CHILD FILTER,
WHICH IS, LIKE, THIS IS JUST
MEAN.
>> BUT THE DEMOCRATS SAY, WE
WANT TO DO A DEAL, THEN DO YOU
THINK THE MEDIA WILL SAY, OKAY,
WILL SUPPORT THEM IN TRYING TO
GET THAT DONE?
>> I THINK THEY'LL DO THAT IF
THEY ACTUALLY GET THE
WHITE HOUSE AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY BECOME ADULTS.
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T HAVE TO.